[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité un permis pour
louer un logement le dispositif doit
permettre de lutter contre l'habitat
indigne mais fait polémique dans la
région bordelaise en cause des critères
trop sévères nous expliquera la
rédaction de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest ils sont deux des plus grandes
légendes du cinéma français Catherine
Deneuve et Alain Delon se mobilise pour
l'Ukraine un an après le début du
conflit les deux stars participeront à
une émission spéciale diffusée sur TV5
Monde que j'aurai le plaisir de
présenter extrait en exclusivité à
découvrir dans ce journal en plein essor
la pratique du MMA se démocratise
partout en France ce sport physique de
combat spectaculaire séduit notamment de
plus en plus les jeunes comme nous le
montrera TVR dans la région rennaise en
Bretagne et puis en fin de journal nous
vous emmènerons dans l'objectif ou
presque d'Harry Potter l'univers de
l'apprenti remercier est devenu la
spécialité d'un photographe rencontre
avec la rédaction de Canal 32
chasser les appartements indécents ou
insalubre du marché de la location c'est
l'objectif du permis à louer ce
dispositif qui vise à lutter contre le
mal logement est entré en vigueur dans
de nouvelles communes depuis le 1er
janvier une demande d'autorisation qui
n'est pas sans causer quelques débats
vous allez le voir et des polémiques son
application suscite aujourd'hui la
colère de propriétaire qui se voit
refuser le droit de louer leur logement
étudiant reportage 10 vents branchis
pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest à
Bordeaux
un simple courrier reçu le 3 février
synonyme de coup de massue pour ses
propriétaires de la résidence rosier
Bellevue à Gradignan ce studio de 22
mètres carrés refait à neuf qui loge
depuis 15 ans de nombreuses étudiants
est aujourd'hui impropre à l'habitation
la valeur locative tombe à zéro de nos
studio et sa grue je ne revenue quant à
moi la conjoncture scalée c'est quand
même un préoccupant on aura pour
obligation une fois que l'arrêté sera
pris de reloger les locataires pour
comprendre l'origine de cet arrêté il
faut alors se rendre à l'extérieur un
logement considéré comme semi enterré
l'un des éléments avancés par Bordeaux
métropole pour annuler le permis de
louer pièce principale de moins de 9
mètres carrés absence de ventilation ou
lumière faible sont également évoquées
conséquences depuis septembre ces deux
studios à 350 euros charges comprises
sont vacants il fait super beau à
l'extérieur la lumière en fait est
naturelle est très agréable et donc tout
au long de la journée les studios sont
suffisamment éclairés personne ne sait
jamais plaint en fait d'un défaut
d'éclairement en particulier ou
d'humidité vous voyez en fait il y a pas
de trace d'humidité sur les murs on est
consterné on ne comprend pas en fait
cette décision une consternation pour
les propriétaires mais également pour
les locataires Paul abitis depuis 4 ans
et devra prochainement quitter les lieux
j'ai des potes qui sont au CROUS et
franchement c'est on est logé à peu près
à la même enseigne c'est le même niveau
de son côté la métropole admet une
situation complexe mais maintient que
malgré des travaux aucun recours n'est
possible le problème c'est que la loi
elle met des règles et que nous notre
mission c'est de faire respecter la loi
donc on n'a pas les capacités et les
moyens de dire bah oui on vous autorise
on vous autorise à déroger à la loi donc
voilà c'est vrai que c'est une situation
qui est qui est complexe parce que ça
rendait service aux propriétaires ça
rendait service aux étudiants on a un
peu plus d'un an 1800 demandes de permis
de louer ont été enregistrés pour une
trentaine de refus dans les
propriétaires de la résidence rosier
Bellevue qui seront prochainement
rencontrés par la métropole en présence
du maire de Gradignan
une journée de manifestation et des
débats encore mouvementés à l'Assemblée
nationale la réforme des retraites n'en
finit plus de faire l'actualité mais
au-delà de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite c'est l'exercice du travail qui
est interrogé dans cette réforme pour
plus de souplesse les salariés de
l'URSSAF de Picardie pourront désormais
choisir de travailler 36 heures en
quatre jours au lieu de 38 en 5 jours un
choix sur la base du volontariat
précision et image recueillies par Wéo
télé la chaîne du Courrier Picard et de
la Voix du Nord les avantages c'est ce
qui nous est demandé c'est un peu plus
de souplesse un peu plus de flexibilité
certains emplois et Métiers s'y prêtent
bien donc la part définition vous avez
un jour de plus offre dans la semaine
les inconvénients on les connaît aussi
c'est que c'est de c'est que c'est des
journées assez longues c'est à dire que
9 heures avec une pause déjeuner au
milieu c'est une journée assez voilà
c'est lourde donc il faut avoir des
activités un peu variées on peut pas
rester 9 heures sur un écran donc il
faut pouvoir voilà alterner certaines
activités à l'international à
l'actualité marqué bien sûr par les
conséquences du séisme qui a touché le
sud de la Turquie et de la Syrie une
tragédie qui a causé la mort de dizaines
de milliers de personnes et qui a
entraîné un élan de mobilisation en
France exemple à Toulouse ou une
association centralise les dons avant
les départs pour les zones sinistrées
reportage de Stéphanie Forgeois pour via
Occitanie sur place
ils viennent de toute la France depuis
le séisme qui a touché la Turquie une
association toulousaine centralise les
dons de différentes associations
françaises le but trier regrouper et
charger des camions qui partiront par la
suite dans le pays sinistré en fait on
va l'ouvrir on va qualifier ce qui à
l'intérieur donc c'est à dire on va vous
donner une fiche vous allez mettre
combien il y a de sartons par exemple de
compresse etc en contact direct avec le
consulat de Bordeaux et le ministère des
Affaires étrangères Nisrine Daoudi
chapote le projet afin que les sept
tonnes de vêtements médicament ou encore
chaises roulantes soit acheminées ou
plus vite en Turquie c'est pour ça qu'en
fait l'association sans frontière elle
est vraiment mobilisée parce que en fait
elle est en temps réel au courant de des
besoins donc ce qui fait que il y a
beaucoup plus de d'envoi etc et si
demain on a plus besoin ben du coup on
arrêtera les la collecte c'est pour ça
qu'en gros aujourd'hui on se mobilise
tout quand on sait que les besoins c'est
au niveau médical ils ont besoin aussi
au niveau de des humains donc on a
envoyé une équipe hugura string et
membre de l'association à Paris
pour lui venir à Toulouse était à la
fois logique et nécessaire
un coup
donc nous on voulait vraiment être sûr
d'avoir une destination finale gérée par
le gouvernement en turc donc vous
l'assurant que ça par avion et sur avoir
un traçage et réceptionner sur place via
une association qui est déjà sur place
le convoi devrait partir ce week-end par
avion et par bateau chacun pouvant
contenir 700 kg de marchandises 3
médecins de l'association sans
frontières sont également partis prêter
main fortes pour l'heure le bilan
provisoire et de plus de 35 000 morts
voilà une situation pour le moins
compliqué au Moyen-Orient qui
questionnent évidemment les technologies
utilisées pour prévenir ce type
d'événement en France le département de
la Loire abrite l'une des 35 stations
sismologiques de l'Observatoire
international GEOSCOPE ces lieux scellés
et dont vous voyez quelques images grâce
à nos partenaires de TL7 sur place
permettent de mesurer précisément les
mouvements du sol survenus dans le monde
entier sans transition Ukraine la guerre
continue de faire rage presque un an
après le début du conflit un triste
anniversaire pour lequel se mobilise
deux monstre sacré du cinéma Catherine
Deneuve et Alain Delon qui
interpréteront chacun des poèmes
Ukrainiens dans le cadre d'une émission
spéciale diffusée sur les antennes de
TV5 Monde vous découvrez la aussi
quelques images de leur venue sur le
plateau de la chaîne et de star
française qui interviendront dans la
même émission que la première dame
ukrainienne au Léna zelenska
regardez cet extrait en exclusivité de
cette émission
une seule espérance me restait revenir
un jour dans ma belle Ukraine
revoir une fois ma terre lointaine
contempler encore le bleu et vivre ou
Montréal un porte bien un peu
qui sert de tombe au milieu de la pleine
immense dans mon Ukraine bien-aimée les
initiales de la liberté sont celles de
la République
des femmes des hommes et de tout ce qui
a vie
liberté capitale de toute nation
face à l'Ukraine avec les interventions
d'Alain Delon et de Catherine Deneuve
notamment sera diffusée les jeudis 23 et
vendredi 24 février à 9h30 jeudi et à
17h vendredi sur TV 5 mois voilà il face
à l'horreur et l'indicible bien souvent
c'est l'arc qui prend le relais Régis
sector dessinateur de presse notamment
réalise depuis un an des dessins sur le
conflit Russo ukrainien des
illustrations partagées sur internet par
le Musée d'Histoire et de la garde de
KEF immersion dans son atelier avec
jean-milon de Moselle TV regardez
pour ce dessin c'est tout simplement
Vladimir Poutine qui se pose aucune
question c'est à dire qu'ils s'endort et
à la place de compter les moutons je les
fais en train de compter les morts le
message est toujours le même dénoncer
les atrocités de la guerre pour cela pas
de grands discours mais des coups de
crayon bien efficaces
j'utilise des bulles donc c'est ma
manière de les aider
avec l'humour et c'est pas toujours
c'est pas toujours un exercice facile
parce que devant certaines exactions
dernièrement il y a eu un Massac
d'enfants je suis désarmée des fois
c'est c'est pas un sujet toujours très
facile et moi je le dis toujours
j'aimerais bien justement un jour dire
que je n'ai plus besoin de faire de
dessin
[Musique]
des idées
régissezctor on a pourtant à l'appel
comme cette terre prête à exploser ou
encore Staline et Hitler berçant leur
petit Poutine
puisque il dit qu'il chasse les nazis
dukraine actuellement celui qui se
conduit comme un nazi c'est bien lui des
dessins qui se retrouvent depuis un an
sur une page internet dédiée au
dessinateur elle est publiée par le
Musée d'Histoire et de la guerre de Kiev
lui-même en tout 41 œuvre reflétant la
résistance inébranlable des Ukrainiens
et la futilité des plans des
envahisseurs sont ainsi à découvrir
passionnés mais surtout très concerné
par cette guerre Régis secteur planche
aujourd'hui sur une BD alors il se
documente
il y a un côté bon je vais pas faire de
l'hyperréalisme non plus mais il faut
faut que je donne de l'authenticité
quand même à mon dessin une BD centrée
sur l'humain plus que la guerre en
elle-même un véritable gage d'espoir
dans un conflit long de bientôt un an
des costumes des masques et beaucoup de
couleurs le carnaval de Venise se tient
jusqu'à mardi prochain en Italie un
événement historique auquel participe
chaque année depuis 35 ans une
association grenobloise son nom les
ineffables les caméras de télé Grenoble
se sont glissés dans leur atelier avant
leur départ cagette boîte d'oeuf
bouteilles en plastique ou encore
bouchon de parfum tous leurs costumes
sont fabriqués à partir de matériaux de
récupération reportage signé Jeanne
créer des masques et des costumes à
partir de matériaux de récupération
c'est l'objectif de l'association Les
ineffables depuis 35 ans ses membres des
fils tous les ans durant 4 jours au
carnaval de Venise et cette année le
thème choisi par les ineffables et la
nature selon l'architecte Gaudi je me
suis inspirée des colonnes de l'église
de la Sagrada Familia et avec les donc
ça c'est les colonnes et ça c'est les
vitraux qui sont soutenus par les
colonnes le masque qui va se composer
donc d'une
armature métallique il va y avoir un
masque style de Venise mais un peu
travaillé et puis derrière il y aura des
vitraux mon idée moi c'était de
refroidir ces fameux toits
extraordinaires avec des tuiles
en forme de perles enfin qui sont
extrêmement esthétiques en tout cas ça
m'a marqué boîte d'oeuf bouteilles en
plastique pâte fimo perles ou encore
bouchon de parfum tout est Recy
transformé pour créer des vêtements et
accessoires uniques l'objectif faire
travailler son imaginaire et partager
des moments créatifs et collectifs les
idées sont véhiculées par les uns par
les autres on a sa propre idée de départ
de ce qu'on a envie et puis suivant les
matériaux la richesse de ce qu'on trouve
on dévie sur sur l'idée ou alors on
confort son idée mais il faut trouver
une solution pour arriver au bout de ce
qu'on avait envie donc ça apporte un
intérêt déjà esthétique parce que on va
quand même très loin au niveau des
techniques et puis ça apporte un grand
bien pour soi-même les membres de
l'association Les unifables défilerons
du 18 au 21 février prochain dans les
rues de Venise leur masque eux seront
utilisés pour d'autres manifestations
extérieures
de l'Italie à la Martinique la saison
des carnavals se poursuit également sur
l'île avant les grands rendez-vous
festifs dès lundi et mardi gras les
habitants sont en pleine finalisation de
leur costume à l'image vous voyez
notamment des parents d'élèves et des
professionnels peaufiner les derniers
détails avant la grande parade organisée
dans les rues de Fort-de-France des
images fournies par nos partenaires sur
place de via TV Martinique et puis on se
mois de février s'il fait beau et chaud
en Martinique en métropole les
températures sont bien plus fraîches
c'est pas un problème néanmoins pour les
enfants en pleine vacances d'hiver
l'économie de vacances notamment battent
leur plein reportage dans l'une d'elles
avec une soixantaine d'apprentis skieur
Benjamin Delmas pour 7 à Limoges
le Lioran la station d'hiver du Cantal
accueille les apprentis skieur limougeot
mise en place par la Ville de Limoges ce
séjour en accessible grâce à ses tarifs
attractifs le chemin des pistes de ski
au 7-17 ans ils sont 67 semaines autant
la semaine prochaine
j'ai un groupe de ski de 10 enfants donc
nous avons effectué dans des Alpins là
les petits sont en train de découvrir
comment ce qui est en parallèle on a
directement attaqué une piste bleue tout
en haut de la montagne au début on a un
peu flippé mais un vrai ça va elle était
trop bien l'occasion pour les jeunes de
découvrir le milieu montagnard mais
surtout de partager de nouvelles
expériences dans un cadre unique c'est
la première station du Massif central
avec 42 pistes 60 km de pistes et une
vingtaine de remontées mécaniques
hébergée au centre du Bec de l'Aigle
propriété de la Ville de Limoges c'est
toute une infrastructure qui rend ce
séjour possible pendant que certains se
démènent dans la poudreuse d'autres
affaires en cuisine on a fait un
activité qui a eu une activité cuisine
donc on a fait des gâteaux au chocolat
des gâteaux au yaourt crumble aux poires
etc et puis après on a on a joué tous
ensemble dans la salle pendant que il y
a d'autres groupes qui étaient au ski
aussi et l'objectif c'est vraiment qu'il
se fasse plaisir nous on est là pour
pour qu'il soit heureux que ça se passe
bien retour sur les pistes pour un
après-midi dédié à la glisse pas
toujours facile de garder son équilibre
dans ses premiers jours dans la
poudreuse une chose est sûre les petits
limo jour ont eu plein de souvenirs
pendant cette colo
longtemps interdit en France les
compétitions de MMA se développent
depuis 3 ans dans l'Hexagone ce sport de
combat impressionnant séduit de plus en
plus d'adeptes en Bretagne une
association propose même des cours
ouverts aux plus jeunes pas de combat en
tant que tel mais des techniques pour
apprendre à se défendre et pour
transpirer aussi un sujet de Capucine
Colin guillochin pour la chaîne TVA à
Rennes regardez
ok c'est parti où les mercredis soirs
malouine et Amel ne vend se donne
rendez-vous pour leur activité
hebdomadaire t-shirt avec des petits
cœurs petite chaussette rose mais ne
vous fiez pas aux apparences
ce soir c'est MMA
dont la pratique et légalisée en France
depuis 2020 seulement le MMA est un
mélange de plusieurs arts martiaux les
combats professionnels se multiplient
dans le pays comme ici à Rennes en
septembre dernier
mais à Guy privé sac pas d'octogone ni
de chaos que des exercices je vais
essayer je dois devenir le chercher aux
jambes mais bon quand même quand on dit
dans la cour de récré qu'on fait du MMA
ça impressionnant les copines
en karaté parce que c'est
des professionnels et alors que nous on
fait plus des exercices pour savoir ce
descendre la seule défense et du sel de
contrôle justement les mamans ont dû en
faire preuve quand les bambins ont
préféré cela au tennis ou au piano par
exemple mais aujourd'hui elles assistent
volontiers aux entraînements des petits
combattants du sol il faut c'est de la
maîtrise debout et puis bon moi je vois
ma douane il se bat pas à l'école pour
autant parler
du coup ça vous montre la caméra
cette année comme Halloween et Amel ils
sont une trentaine à pratiquer dans le
dojo des grands des petits costauds ou
un peu moins et ce n'est pas qu'un
défouloir vos conditions physiques c'est
très intéressant pour regarder la forme
pour les jeunes ça leur donne la
confiance ça permettra il a coordination
l'appréhension de la chute aussi c'est
important je trouve
[Musique]
allez partons à la découverte maintenant
dans ce journal de nos savoir-faire
locaux avec d'abord la rencontre du seul
vinaigrier de la région savoyarde une
histoire de reconversion pour Benoît
badin qui récupère son vin localement
pour le transformer en vinaigre tantôt
rouge tantôt blanc ces produits sont
déjà vendus dans plusieurs grandes
surfaces une rencontre vinaigrée
forcément signée maintenant toi t'y pour
8 Mont-Blanc
on pourrait presque dire qu'il est tombé
dans le vinaigre par hasard Benoît badin
était chef de projet dans l'énergie
hydroélectrique il voyageait beaucoup et
souhaitait retrouver du sens dans sa
profession l'idée de sa reconversion en
tant que vinaigriers est arrivée quelque
temps après un peu par surprise la vraie
vraie histoire c'est qu'en fait j'ai eu
le flash en finissant une bouteille de
vinaigre un soir de juillet 2021 et son
est suivi une petite éclat de rire et en
se disant ah je crois que j'ai trouvé et
puis depuis j'ai déroulé la pelote et me
voilà depuis plusieurs mois il produit
son vinaigre dans son atelier à La
Biolle Benoît a tout appris sur le tas
grâce à ses connaissances en chimie il
vérifie la qualité de sa production avec
des méthodes d'un autre temps alors
cette partie c'est une partie de
contrôle qualité je dirais je suis en
train de m'assurer que le vinaigre que
je produis est à 6 degrés d'acidité ce
qui est une norme réglementaire pour le
vinaigre de 2020 il faut compter au
moins trois mois pour avoir un produit
fini et c'est dans une pièce chauffée
que la magie opère les tonneaux abritent
une mer de vinaigre et Benoît ajoute du
vin petit à petit pour la nourrir il a
fait le choix de ne travailler qu'avec
des produits locaux et pour rester local
ses premiers clients sont à 50 mètres de
chez lui ce restaurateur travaille avec
des produits de la région et quand on
lui a dit qu'il pouvait même trouver du
vinaigre à côté de chez lui il a sauté
sur l'occasion
de très bonnes choses très bon
producteur très bon produit aux
alentours pourquoi aller voir ailleurs
en fait Benoît il est à
50 mètres du restaurant il y a vraiment
un savoir-faire derrière et on sent
quand même vraiment une différence au
niveau du goût des recettes du travail
en tout cas Benoît espère pouvoir
produire jusqu'à 15000 litres de
vinaigre par an son produit se trouve
déjà en tête de gondole de plusieurs
grandes surfaces aux alentours et pour
une fois espérons pour lui que le
tournera au vinaigre
nous partons dans l'Ariège dans ce
journal lui il est le seul gardien d'une
tradition historique Pascal jusseau est
un artisan sabotier le dernier de sa
vallée un métier rare et précieux se
passionné confectionne chacune de ces
pièces seul avec du bois issu de forêts
locales et à l'aide d'outils spécifiques
du modelage à la personnalisation cette
artisan répète inlassablement les mêmes
gestes depuis plus de 30 ans une
longévité qu'il doit notamment à la
production et à la vente de Sabo de
jardin images et précision de Clément
cassis pour la Dépêche du Midi
il y a une demande de plus en plus
importante pour les jardiniers pour le
côté solide ça chaude naturel et voilà
et durable en fait c'est tout l'inverse
du caoutchouc le bois ou du plastique
Franck Le Creney est un photographe
indépendant fait rude des 24 Heures du
Mans un amour pour la course mythique
qui lui a permis de décrocher la
médaille d'or nationale de photographie
sportive prochaine étape la Coupe du
monde d'ailleurs dans les lauréats
seront connues le 17 mars prochain un
sujet d'Anthony Python pour elle mtvart
dans le viseur de Franck Le Creney les
voitures de course ce photographe
professionnel est installé dans l'Orne
il y a un mois les médailles de la
photographie française lui décernaient
lors dans la catégorie Sport pour ce
cliché de l'édition 2022 des 24 heures
c'est une image que je souhaitais faire
depuis longtemps mais c'est vrai qu'on a
pas toujours la chance d'avoir ce soleil
aussi orangé au lever du jour quoi
d'ailleurs ça a été un peu difficile et
il a fallu se faire violence parce que
il faut voilà accéder aussi se relever
se déverrouiller après avoir dormi deux
trois heures dans sa voiture car avec la
photo les 24 Heures du Mans c'est la
grande passion de Franck depuis plus de
40 ans il accumule les prises de vue
autour du circuit des photos qui classe
ensuite précieusement par année là on
reconnaît Jean Rondeau également à la
remise des prix donc
quelqu'un d'illustre sur Le Mans qui a
gagné en 1980 c'était génial quoi c'est
c'est un petit moment de l'année un peu
particulier où j'y vais vraiment
vraiment avec plaisir quoi puis le
challenge c'est un petit peu de réaliser
de nouvelles images sur des endroits que
j'ai pas réalisés donc voilà ça me fait
plaisir le jour où il pleut ça me fait
presque plaisir parce que ça permet de
faire des images différentes au fil de
ces clichés Franck Le crenet a acquis
une solide réputation dans le métier à
tel point qu'il va représenter la France
lors de la Coupe du monde de la
photographie dans la catégorie hard
digitale parmi les nombreux autres
projets de Franck l'idée de publier un
livre un jour peut-être pour partager
ses plus beaux clichés des 24 Heures du
Mans
voilà et des clichés automobiles aux
apprentis sorciers la photographie ne
connaît pas de limite dans son
expression artistique la preuve avec
cette fois-ci le succès d'un
professionnel spécialisé dans l'univers
d'Harry Potter à travers son appareil il
propose de s'immerger dans l'univers
magique de Poudlard et de ses élèves
reportage de la rédaction de Canal 32
sur place
et puis dessus on va faire une photo je
pense que tu vas faire semblant d'écrire
voilà la plume c'est dans son studio à
mairie sur scène que la magie de Jérémy
pinson au père avec le film Harry Potter
en fond ces modèles posent avec le
Nimbus de 1000 ou en compagnie du jeune
sorcier donc au début j'avais le fond et
en fait ce que je faisais c'est que je
détourais donc Harry Potter c'est venu
comme ça au mois de novembre j'ai
détouré sur un faux manche à balai ma
fille et du coup je l'ai mis sur un
terrain de Quidditch et là ça a plu j'ai
vu que ça a plu et il y a eu des fans
comme ça des clients pour d'autres
choses et j'ai fait le marché de Noël
des trucs comme ça qui m'ont dit Harry
Potter c'est bien donc du coup j'ai
commencé à investir dedans après avoir
travaillé plusieurs années en tant que
commercial le méritien s'est reconverti
d'abord dans le graphisme puis est
devenu photographe il a ouvert son
studio en septembre 2022 au fil du temps
jérémy a acquis une collection
importante d'objets qu'il met à
disposition de ses clients pour le
shooting
ensuite place à la magie grâce au
logiciel de retouche de la première
photo que j'ai sorti en mois de novembre
d'Harry Potter aujourd'hui ça n'avait
encore plus rien à voir par contre le
grain restera maintenant toujours le
même je voulais qu'il y a un côté
affiche un côté peinture c'est le
scénario en fait que je vais chercher
maintenant objectif proposer une
immersion dans le monde magique des
sorciers de Poudlard une expérience pour
tous les fans ça peut toucher les
adultes mais osent prendre en photo
c'est ça en fait par contre le petit le
compromis qui est dur à faire pour les
adultes on aimerait bien en fait être à
la place de nos enfants mais faut passer
derrière la caméra et enfin devant et
c'est compliqué quoi je veux vraiment
que le fan il puisse toucher à des
objets qu'il a pas l'habitude d'avoir
chez lui parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un coup le photographe propose d'autres
prestations mais celles-ci plaît
particulièrement Jérémy fourmis d'idées
il aimerait proposer une exposition ou
encore réaliser des courts métrages sur
le thème d'Harry Potter
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]